[Musique]
thierry colère bonjour oui bonjour les
attend alors vous êtes candidat aux
élections municipales et communautaires
on le rappelle à saint-joseph alors ce
n'est pas la première fois vous me
rappeliez justement quand 95 vous étiez
déjà candidat alors pourquoi avoir
choisi d'y retourner
ben déjà d'une part parce que il me
semblait que c'était normal de revenir
avec une équipe dans la mesure où un
certain nombre de choses n'ont pas
avancé depuis une dizaine d'années dans
la commune en tout cas à partir d'autres
manières de voir un donc il y a seul le
problème notamment des problèmes
financiers
les volumes d'orientation politique
assène le problème donc il fallait
absolument que l'équipe nouvelle
alors l'équipe est nouvelle mais la tête
de liste elle n'est pas nouvelle mais
c'est une équipe nouvelle jeune avec des
personnes qui n'ont jamais milité
d'accord qu'elle n'a jamais milité et
qui ont envie de se donner de donner du
temps pour la population une équipe
rajeunie aussi en âge absolument
absolument
ce sera je pense à surprises on n'a pas
fait exprès mais ce soit des personnes
jeunes entre 35 et 40 ans qui sont venus
me voir me dire non il faut revenir il
faut revenir à cette élection
tu as l'habitude tu as fait des
propositions en 2014 qui était bonne on
t'a pas suivi mais non il faut venir il
faut proposer la population et on voit
aussi que celui qu'on traitait de sens
en mangeant sain je le dis de traite ya
un certain nombre d'années
avait raison par rapport à l'actualité
alors justement on ne sait toujours pas
si le maire sortant athanase rose
atteints d'un syndrome va se présenter
on entend un jour peut-être que oui un
autre certainement que non parce que bon
voila il a eu des bons le cd des ennuis
judiciaires il a été condamné il a fait
un pourvoi en cassation
du coup ça a créé un contexte
particulier dans cette commune de saint
joseph vous vous confirmez est-ce que ça
oui ça colle contexte particulier ferai
jamais les depuis l'âge de 18 ans sur
saint joseph c'est la première fois que
je vis une campagne aussi froides au
seafood costa maintenant pour parler de
moi et de mon équipe
on n'est pas candidat parce qu'il ya une
opportunité ou par opportunisme
on est candidat parce qu'on a des
convictions j'ai des convictions et j'ai
un projet que je vais proposer à la
population je fume et la mener à bien
avec elle vous avez l'investiture du ppm
alors la particularité
- le soutien peut être oui peut-être
mais vous savez ne pas en parler avec
nature au fossé sans pour l'instant pour
l'instant non vous l'avez demandé vous
allez là doit dire la demande et vous
l'avez demandé
oui absolument mais il faut savoir que
comme tous les candidats ne se sont pas
encore désignés je pense que est normal
que le parti attendent
oui parce que athanase jeanne rose a été
élu maire alors qu'il était dans un
ensemble pour une martinique nouvelle
absolument on fait partie de ce que
c'est un ami a priori du ppm
on peut le voir comme ça bon quel serait
votre priorité si vous êtes élu maire
thierry colère pour la ville de
saint-joseph alors mais en tant que
maire du point de vue de la municipalité
oui et du voodoo lounge adam malysz et
même avant l'aspect financier parce
qu'on connaît les problèmes des
collectivités et notamment celle de
saint joseph
ce sera d'abord de parler de discuter
avec le ps la halle municipale de
communiquer avec elle et de travailler
alors sous le thème réformes
vous savez on a très peur des réformes
mais ceux de travail et mettre en place
des procédures
qui qui devra répondre aux besoins de la
population
oui aux besoins du projet 1 donc m
l'équipe municipale en ordre manche en
ordre de manche
que ce soit les élus et le personnel
municipal
je pense que c'est prioritaire parce que
on ne peut pas réussir un mandat
politique
si l'outil n'est pas n'est pas adéquat
et aujourd'hui c'est le cas aujourd'hui
on voit une démobilisation du personnel
on voit des crispations et tout ça voilà
merci thierry colère ben oui les cinq
minutes sont déjà passés ça va très vite
candidat donc aux élections municipales
et communautaires à saint joseph
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
elles c'est beaucoup